well I said hi i'm ricardo view in a
waiver i come from Bucaramanga Colombia
and I'm a ballet dancer and I'd like you
to come with me and discover the charms
of Leipzig to get things started here we
are at the main railway station let's go
Wow it's fantastic I'm thrilled it's
more than I expected meaning it had all
these perfect architectural details they
contrast with the modern building it
can't be compared with the railway
stations in my country well as returns
to the enemy base fantastic
you can once again because I'm a
Catholic I can't leave out a visit to a
church what's the one behind me in st.
Thomas you is that little Moscovici you
are you want a bastion ba a great
composer and very important to this
church mean for my son kawawa bak played
an important role in my education as a
dancer he gave him my musical roots I
enjoy him just as much as i do latin
american with
so any more i feel so emotional hay
lugares it's very moving to know Johann
Sebastian Bach composed many of his best
musical works in this place for this
with me what is not that music Alice I'm
Catholic and although this
churches-lutheran I'm fascinated by the
solemnity of this place yeah the people
is very symbolic being here we apply my
pico por estar aqui
camion lovely types of town hall
majestic
Wow what are you impressive space it's
marvelous incredible it inspires me to
dance and as a Latino I take music alone
with me let's dance what was our lab
you
let's play after 250 steps my reward is
the view from the Town Hall towers
lateral Norrell rattles yarra Lama says
now we're going to explore a part of
life secrets different and not touristy
I'm at the port of Lyndon now a place in
the west of the city that's about to be
developed for me the place retains a
great deal of charm what's this can I
drive this train
little train yeah slow train oh honey
I'm enjoying the trip
spectacular spectacular now I never
thought life would be so green with so
much nature it's enchanting encanto
got off now let's go and enjoy life
socialite life yakky I've heard they
play Salta here let's check it out
I've changed my clothes so I can enjoy
the sod some more come on let's go
Oh
this has been one spectacular day in
life see I wouldn't change it for
anything and German women dance very
well